Dr Armin this is Officer long I'm  detective smart you must be to rise to  the rank of detective  this is my beautiful son Roman  now you must be very proud  first I had to convince this detective  that I hadn't murdered my wife but  almost more importantly I had to make  sure that my son had the breakfast he so  desired where were you when you first  discovered your wife's body I was  deciding whether to sever her  ties to me you're not intimidate me with  your fancy shirt I know what you did is  it okay if I go I just prepared A Feast  for you  but the jokes on him more for me  what's wrong with you like your face  isn't even moving your wife just died  what would be a more appropriate thing  for me to do with my face have it moved  since my tear ducts are now closed the  only way I can cry is through my mouth  [Music]